Jake Paul good for boxing or is he bad
for boxing answer for me
I'm I'm the best thing that's happened
to boxing in a century
[Music]
all right well
um for starters thank you so much for
this free trip to Puerto Rico
did I pay for it it never worked it
let's go
let's go so since we want to come
interview you we all got this you know
all expenses paid trip to San Juan it's
beautiful here it is very pretty so it's
so awesome I love it do you feel you're
welcome you're welcome thank you so much
do you feel like a bit more at peace
here in Puerto Rico sure
I just feel like myself I think when you
you know are in LA or
Miami yeah or Vegas you know it's just
Madness and there's so many distractions
pulling you in so many different areas
and
you know life just gets too crazy in
those places for me and here I'm just
able to focus on myself and I think
that's what I need you know as a young
man yeah well I mean how long did it
take you to be like okay I actually want
the piece
and not the craziness and do you
genuinely feel that way are you just
think it's the right thing for you
um I think it took a couple of years of
you know being in that environment and
realizing you know oh this is like cool
no wait wait a second this isn't cool no
like I don't like these people I don't
this isn't me this isn't who I actually
am yeah you know I grew up playing
sports and I grew up you know just
living my life in the outdoors nature
and that was really it and I moved to LA
and get mixed up and all these other
things
but when I came back to here to Puerto
Rico that's when I like felt like myself
again and I would just focused on Sports
focus on you know living a chill life
and of course you know the chaos is fun
there's parts of me that miss it for
sure but I think that part of my life
was like college and I was like I was
like a frat kid yeah and I had to get it
out of my system you know then there's
nothing wrong with that but I feel old
now even though I'm young I'm like all I
do is
just business and training yeah I mean I
do feel like the the craziness kind of
wears on you after a little bit for sure
yeah for sure and it's a dead end which
people don't realize like all the party
and [ __ ] and clubs it seems cool and
maybe every once in a while like if
you're doing it here and there but when
that becomes your life which in L.A bro
these I'm telling you these kids are
crazy yeah okay every day wake up party
wake up party wake up party and you just
buy a way of Osmosis you automatically
just get sort of looped into it
because that's what everyone else is
doing so if you're not doing it then
you're the weird one Loki yeah well you
know people are saying I was in Puerto
Rico and everyone's like why are you in
Puerto Rico I'm like oh I'm interviewing
Jake Paul he lives here a lot of people
not too happy I'm here uh talking to you
I wish I I don't know if that's
surprising to you or if you don't expect
that yeah not at all uh you know that
that happens all the time people are
like
why are you talking to him like ESPN did
an article and like all the you know
ESPN writers were like
yelling at the other writer who was
doing the story like why are you giving
him a platform what that kid sucks
look at him he looks like a thumb uh
which I do
I'm sorry but I can't control the way I
look
uh but I I get it I get it for sure you
know I'm a very polarizing figure and
that's part of my brand you know I think
years and years of controversy and like
all that sort of [ __ ] made me the bad
guy and so I was like okay fine you guys
want me to be the bad guy I'll be the
bad guy and now I just have fun with it
well I mean how does it feel to say like
being polarizing is a part of my brand
like your brand is being polarizing
correct
yeah does that feel strange that that is
the thing that is kind of
all-encompassing with you
um there's definitely a disconnect but
like I've gotten used to it and
especially with boxing it's like ever
there needs to be a villain you know
yeah there needs to be every movie has a
bad guy so you know as far as I'm
concerned I actually enjoy it because
someone does need to ruffle the feathers
and then parts of me are like damn like
I'm you know kind of OD right now you
know rubbing people the wrong way or
whatever but
it is what it is and you know
at the end of the day I got bills to pay
a family to provide for
30 employees
so we need to keep the lights on and the
way I found to do that is by being the
bad guy and proving everyone wrong with
my boxing ability because everyone wants
to see me get in the ring and to get
knocked out yeah people want to see you
get knocked out 100 and I love it you
know tune in pay the money because it's
going straight to my bank account into
my friend's bank accounts and my
family's bank accounts and my employees
bank accounts and my mom's bank account
so they're literally
paying for my whole future after this
fight I could retire for the rest of my
life so if I have to be the bad guy I
could give a [ __ ] yeah well what
specific thing is it about your
personality that you think like breeds
this resentment with people
I think a lot of people are censor
themselves
with the way they speak or their
thoughts and I just don't do that and
that I think is what pisses people off
because they don't agree with the way I
think about things they don't agree with
the way I see the world they think I'm a
cringe they think I'm annoying they
think I'm cocky that you know they'll
have a big ego or whatever it is
are you any of those things yeah for
sure for sure but like also you know
everything you see
on camera in Hollywood
or on Instagram it's not real and our
generation should know that by now like
if you if you look at someone's
Instagram and think you can judge their
life or their Tick Tock or their YouTube
or watching this interview if you think
you can judge my life right now based
off of this interview then you're
ignorant and [ __ ] because until you
actually know me for five ten years like
you can't judge me I can't judge you I
can sit here and read a bunch of stuff
about everyone in this room I can see
this [ __ ] you've done when you were 20
years old if I had a camera on this guy
he looks crazy I bet he was doing some
[ __ ] when he was 20. if I had cameras on
everyone in this room their whole entire
life which is what I had to do then
you'd probably see some [ __ ] that was
like whoa that's weird or that guy's oh
that wasn't cool or they if everyone
were getting into a controversy and so
for me I just learn and grow from it and
I can't judge other people and they
can't judge me yeah well I guess that
kind of begs the question people saying
well like you did have the camera on you
and you still you know did whatever
these controversial things are and
that's probably what the rebuttal would
be to someone who would say something
like that because obviously everybody
makes mistakes everybody does really
dumb things when they're young but
they're not seen but it's almost like
you make the choice for those things to
be seen if that makes sense no I think a
lot of it was ignorance like being like
you said a young 20 something year old
19 year old is when like when I was 19
20 and 21 is when maybe actually mostly
19 and 20. you know I was living in
Hollywood with all my best friends and I
thought I was invincible and I had money
I had all this [ __ ] that I ever wanted
power and Baba and I just mismanaged it
yeah and
to pay for that you know like it's not
been easy you know people have
reprimanded me and tore me down and
canceled me and I've had to learn and
grow for sure but it's made me a better
person and that's all you can do is
learn from your mistakes and I'm still
not perfect I know I'm going to do some
dumb [ __ ] uh you know but that's just
who I am and I'm not afraid to
of anyone I'm not afraid of anything I'm
not afraid of being canceled for
living my life you know and I'm
definitely a lot more cautious a lot
more calculated and you know
a different person
than who I was even two months ago I'm
maturing I think boxing has helped me
with that as well because and getting
out of that world and that lifestyle
where you know
if I did some stupid [ __ ] Loki I would
get more attention from it and more
followers and more conversation and so
when you're a YouTuber an influencer
and you start to realize like oh if I do
some something that's going to cause
some trouble it's going to piss some
people off but they're just going to
talk about me my engagement goes up My
Views go up and then the people who
don't care will just become fans yeah so
it's this unhealthy life like cycle yes
I was going to say that feels like super
unhealthy yeah to have to be you know
your actions are based off the
engagement or the conversation
um and I just wonder like how that kind
of makes you feel at your core or made
you feel at your core for me at the time
I didn't realize how unhealthy it was at
the time
no one in my family was ever Rich no one
in my family had anything
no one in my family
you know we were eating a hamburger
helper growing up you know five dollar
pizzas so
boom I'm seeing the money go up and I'm
like
oh wow
I like this because no one in my
family's ever accomplished anything so I
really at the time I was very selfish I
didn't care about much of anything else
other than oh wow I'm becoming
successful
and so
you know I could buy my mama Rolex I
could buy my dad the Harley that he had
to sell when he was losing all of his
money
and he cried overall selling everything
in his house I can now
you know get that stuff back and that's
all I really cared about at the time
so you obviously have done so many
things you fit into kind of a bunch of
different boxes and someone said to you
why are you famous
tell me why are you famous [ __ ] I don't
know
that's probably the most I've watched a
lot of your interviews and that's the
most honest answer you have ever given
yeah I do not know why I'm famous yeah I
mean if you really boiled it down it's
like I made a vine when I was 15 with my
brother that went viral and it sort of
just all started there yeah but that's
like the that's like the calculated
answer but you know one thing led to
another and I would just say I'm an
Entertainer but like wow I don't know
and at this point
it's like The Snowball Effect so
it just keeps on getting bigger I guess
is Jake Paul good for boxing or is he
bad for boxing
answer for me I'm I'm the best thing
that's happened to boxing in a century
period you know and the the Legends
would agree and that Anthony Joshua's
the Mike Tysons the Manny Pacquiao's the
Tyson furies
they've all said what I'm doing for
boxing is a breath of fresh air I think
that debate you know
started
about a year ago is Jake Paul good for
boxing uh
I I have silenced that and I don't think
there's anybody on the other side of the
equation who thinks I'm bad for boxing
I'm bringing more fans uh I'm I have a
foundation where we give boxing gloves
to as many kids as possible we're going
around renovating boxing gyms getting
the young kids inspired to box I think
this sport needed that uh Revival and
that younger audience to come in and
really reinvigorated because it was
dying out it was boring and I brought a
new social media wave to it where now
Fighters are copying everything I do on
social media to promote their fights you
know I'm doing things differently I got
LED screens in my shorts I got a boxing
mascot transformer robot you know I'm
I'm shaking the tree and I think in old
dying things this tree needs to be
shaken
do you feel like you I don't say this is
a bad thing you have made everyone feel
like they can become a boxer
they can
and they could become a world champion
if they want to
they just obviously it's hard as [ __ ]
yeah you know and you have to have
natural talent but
that's the beautiful thing about it is
if you feel like you have something to
fight for then you can become a boxer
and boxing changed my life and I'm gonna
prove that you know that's the beautiful
thing about this is I'm going to become
a world champion
because everyone said I couldn't and
that I wasn't a real boxer and and they
were saying is this kid good for boxing
so I'm literally just gonna do it just
to prove everyone wrong and to show you
know the the nine-year-old or the
eight-year-old who's watching this
interview that that you don't need to
listen to anybody anything or anybody
any sorry I can't speak I've been
training uh anybody anything anyone says
Jesus Christ uh you just don't
well
why why should I let someone tell me I
can't do something and that's really
like the hidden message in all of this
is just showing people that anything is
possible because it truly is if you work
hard and have a will greater than
anybody else's
so another criticism as I'm sure you
know is you're like well he's not
fighting real boxers what's your
response to that and how can you put
yourself in this category if you have
not done that yet I mean I'm fighting a
real boxer now you know December 18th uh
in Tampa Bay Emily Arena fighting Tommy
Fury he's a has a decorated amateur
background he comes from a legendary
bloodline of Fighters The Fury family is
famous his older brother is the
heavyweight champion of the world he's
undefeated same age same height same
weight
uh and he's a professional boxer
whatever whatever that means so of
course you know people are gonna have
criticisms and I welcome it and it only
you know draws more attention and
motivates me to work harder but I quite
literally am fighting a real boxer now
and like I said this has been
20 months this has been literally 20
months so what I've accomplished in 20
months is unprecedented and everyone
needs to take a chill pill because I can
only do so much as fast as these fights
can get signed is as fast as I'm going
to do them so
I'll fight everybody this started with
me calling out McGregor and people were
like oh that kid's crazy McGregor would
kill him
and now it's like
that fight could happen in the next 24
months 100 they probably will and I will
beat him so people just like
are seen how serious I am about this and
changing the way they think about it is
that McGregor conversation happening it
has been happening for for a while
you know we're talking to his team and
it makes sense you know he wanted me to
get more fights under my belt and build
up my name build up my pay-per-view buys
and that's exactly what I've done so
you know we're coming to that Crossroad
very shortly where are we at with uh
Jake Paul Canelo with any updates no
updates I mean that that's something
that's never been in conversation but
again
you know all I gotta do is win
which I will and that's what I dedicate
myself to doing every single day
is winning
and the Jake Paul Canelo fight will
definitely happen Okay but so when we
talk about you fighting McGregor I can
tell by the way you're talking about
you're like oh no I would win that you
feel very certain that you would be
McGregor I'm sure a lot of people are
watching are like all right is he
serious like he can meet McGregor
but you do feel and seem very like you
believe that you genuinely could I know
I will 110 and I think a lot of people
watching at home you know
they're probably watching on their mom's
Wi-Fi or some [ __ ] like they can't do it
they couldn't beat McGregor they
couldn't accomplish that [ __ ] and so
that's why they think I can't
but I know I can and that's why y'all
are watching me and it's not the other
way around
because I'm doing great [ __ ] I'm
accomplishing great [ __ ] and I know what
I'm capable of and no one can tell me
otherwise and so people watching on
their little tick tocks or Instagrams or
YouTube you know they're sitting there
being like this kid's crazy blah blah
blah I don't care like
that person can't do it the doubters are
the ones who can't do [ __ ] in life and
so they try to
you know put that onto other people and
make other people feel like they can't
do stuff so
that's really
that's really what it is and I know I'll
win 110 so what's your ceiling as a
boxer
there there is none you know it says
it's as far as I want to take it the
only person that
can defeat me as myself
and that's really the truth you know
you know so I put out um I think it's on
my Instagram story I was like who has a
question for Jake Paul if you could talk
to Jake Paul what would you ask
there's a contention of the internet
that really does feel like your fights
aren't real and I'm sure you're aware of
this what's your response to people not
believing your fights really you have a
knockout clause and all these things
that it's all made for you to win
yeah I mean first of all that's illegal
like highly illegal because you involve
gambling and like odds makers and people
betting on the fights
and so like I would be in jail if I was
manipulating that much money because
it's illegal first and foremost so if if
there was actually something in my
contracts that were like oh this you
have to do this or that
I would be in jail first and foremost
and I look at it as a compliment because
people just don't want to believe my
ability
and
I've knocked you know most everyone out
in the first round and it looks
it looks fake but that's just how good I
am and I beat a five-time UFC champion
and of course people are going to have
excuses and they're going to do anything
they can to discredit me that's what
happens when you're number one
can you because you know Dana White is
one of the people that kind of
insinuated that this stuff isn't true
walk me through like this Feud that
you've got with Dana White who started
it who's gonna end it how does it end I
want yeah I want to know uh what's going
on with that it all started back in 2000
uh it started when I was fighting Ben
askren okay and
he said on a podcast
on Mike Tyson's podcast that he would
bet a million dollars that I would lose
to Ben asgren so that's where it all
started and he then
got Ben askren to go and train with
Freddie Roach who's like a legendary
boxing trainer
and was trying to you know do all this
stuff to get him to win and we just
started going back and forth and
I beat Ben in a minute and 59 seconds
and Dana was just silent he couldn't
believe it of course then his only thing
is so that he doesn't look like an idiot
it's a you know insinuate that these are
rigged insinuate that these fights
aren't real he's doing anything to save
his ass because I'm beating all of the
guys that were dominant in his League
the the UFC and so it's a bad look for
his whole entire company and
organization so you know he's smart he's
a smart guy super smart guy and he's
going to do anything he can to discredit
me
but again it just makes the numbers go
up and
it is what it is have you had any
one-on-one conversations with Dana
I don't think so no
I have not so all of this is just
podcast podcast I say this you say that
where's my money yeah okay and now it's
fun for me like yeah because I see how
mad he gets and I'm just like that
that's what people don't get like when
I'm trolling
I'm having I'm just laughing like I'll
literally just be sitting there in my
room on my phone just laughing at like
all the jokes I'm making and I see how
pissed off it makes these Meat Heads I
call them like Meat Heads because they
don't know anything or any other emotion
and just like get angry and like react
so it's like it's like they're my
puppets and I just get them to like
react however exactly I want them to
and I'm just always one step ahead so
for me it's just fun like I see him get
all mad and say all this stuff and like
I just laugh at it because he's an old
fat miserable man
you know so I
it's just funny man how does the feud
end
how do you want the feud to end
man
I would say a sword battle to the death
would be pretty dope you versus Dana
White pay-per-view
sword battle to the death
nah I mean who knows if it ends it might
never end
I think eventually he's gonna have to do
business with me and let his UFC
Champions come over and box me you know
just like he did with Connor and Floyd
because at the end of the day money
talks and
he's a smart guy he wants to make money
for the UFC so he's going to let a
champion come over and we'll probably do
a co-promotion where I'm fighting Conor
Kamara Usman or whoever it is
I mean I think it's very clear you are a
very confident person
um everything you say it comes from some
place of confidence but what are you not
confident about
I'm not good at skateboarding
and that's about it
uh there's a lot of stuff I'm not
confident about and I'm not I'm not
afraid to say that I think you know I'm
still figuring out who I am as a young
man and you know I feel like I'm
shy sometimes and like awkward in like
social situations
um
you know
if you ask me to go up on stage and
dance in front of people I'd be like I
don't want to really do that right now
uh
uh I don't know there's a lot of stuff
you know I think everyone has
insecurities and if they act like they
don't then
they're they're the ones with even
bigger insecurities it takes courage to
admit that you have insecurities and I
think
all of us do it's just human nature yeah
what's the thing you like the least
about yourself my nose crooked from
boxing
can you see that's the thing I mean
that's like only because you pointed out
I would have never thought that because
I I broke my nose meditating I like
passed out before one of my fights I was
like meditating long story
the Nate Robinson fight you passed out
before that 30 30 days before so I like
I fought that fight with a broken nose
yeah
yeah it's crazy but uh
yeah so
it got like a little bit crooked and
then through just like sparring it just
like keeps on
getting a little bit more Computing so
the thing that you're most insecure
about is something with your appearance
nothing in your personality
you know I think my I make dad jokes a
lot that aren't funny
like I still have like Disney Channel
humor from being on Disney Channel
Do you know what you do like if I ask
you a question that you may be like I
don't know you always go to humor is
humor just like a thing that you do if
you don't know exactly what you want to
say
probably I mean that's how my family is
everything's a joke and everyone just
like makes fun of each other and like
yeah I think when you've had a lot of
trauma in your life too
comedy comes from Pain what trauma in
your life are you referring to man so
much [ __ ]
I don't even know if I want to get into
it but
just I mean everyone has their own [ __ ]
you know I'm not saying my life was
harder than anyone else's or whatever
but everyone has their own their [ __ ]
that they go through yeah but are there
certain things you've gone through like
you think about every day that you feel
they are affecting you every day is you
have an example of one thing
for sure
um
[Music]
I think
I think what it goes back to like I mean
the first thing that I'm like feel
comfortable sharing is when your whole
life is put on display all the time and
it's like judged like those comments and
stuff for the longest time they would
like eat me away and like the hate
really uh like affected me for sure and
I didn't like it at all uh and I had to
get to a point where I was confident
enough in myself to like really not care
what anyone says but that wasn't easy
and I think I still live with
a lot of those
comments and things that people said and
that like feeling of like
uh validation like always like
you know seeking validation from other
people because the internet will never
like give you that and so I had to get
to a place where I was confident enough
in myself but I think you know that
lingering trauma of like seeking
validation is always there yeah because
sometimes I wonder I'm like okay well
when are we getting like Jay Paul and
when are we getting like the character
of Jake Paul and I'm sure because you've
been doing this for so long the lines
are probably blurred for you too at
times
like how often are you trying to figure
out which one is you which one is made
up I I wouldn't say I I don't I don't
have a character I think it's always me
it just like
I
can
you know
turn it up when I need to in certain
instances like I can go into a business
meeting and be super smart educational
you know talk about stocks bonds cryptos
nfts you know day trading whatever or I
could go and turn into a killer in the
ring and beat the [ __ ] out of somebody
and make them bleed all over the floor
and not give a [ __ ] about it or I could
sit here like on today it's a Monday I'm
super chill
like I'm super tired so I'm just like
super you know just chilling yeah so
it's always a it's always me it just
like I'm in different moods a lot of the
time I think I'm a very like Moody
person so sometimes imma act up
sometimes I'm gonna be funny sometimes
they're gonna be chill
that's and I think people see a lot of
[ __ ] that I do
you know and they pool from whichever
one they want to my fans love the this
Jake the the people hate the you know
loud mouth cocky Jake
so you know I guess it's different each
day I don't know
did the face to face to face which is
very entertaining you were both very
funny in it but one thing that he
insinuated was cultural appropriation
from you
and you know online there are people
that feel like you do do that do you
understand why some people say that
about you
um I don't
I really don't I think it's a reach
in what ways
it's just like I don't get how I'm
how people could say that
doesn't make sense to me well I think
they're referencing I don't know maybe
the way you dress or you know I think
the big thing is they say okay well once
he entered into this like boxing arena
he kind of changed how he was how he
dressed how he acted which they then
feel like you're appropriating the
culture once you got here but maybe
feeling like you don't Black Culture got
you
nah I mean
I'm I'm young and I'm still you know
figuring out the things I like you know
and I'm influenced by certain things
and if I see streetwear or jewelry or
whatever and I want to wear it then I
like that you know that's me that's my
style and so if I'm being me and people
think I'm culturally appropriating some
something then I I don't like get get
over it I'm just dressing I'm not I
don't wake up in the morning and be like
I'm gonna steal this that's stupid as
hell I don't I
it's a reach that's what I'm saying yeah
well I mean just just to play Devil's
Advocate I think that when people talk
about cultural appropriation I don't
know if they necessarily think that you
are intentionally saying I want to do
this I want to act like this black
person whatever the case may be I think
black people feel like someone's
appropriating if they're doing things
that are considered like black
mainstream but maybe aren't caring about
black topics or black issues and that is
where the term is coming from I don't
think anybody thinks you're
intentionally
doing that but that's what it comes off
as to others gotcha
so I don't know if it's as much if it
reaches it's just like a thing that
maybe
hasn't been presented to you
um in that way
does that make sense yeah no no it makes
sense okay I mean I would love to talk
to with you about it like and learn more
you know off camera because like I don't
know I but again I'm not I'm not doing
anything to harm anybody yeah no it
makes sense but you know that's what
they mean I don't think it's some
intentional thing that that they believe
to be true
um I was reading something where you
said that audio mirror you write things
right that are motivational to you or to
remind you of certain things tell me
three of the things that are written on
your mirror
uh one of them says I Jake Paul will
knock out defeat and embarrass Tommy
Fury in December 18th live on Showtime
um another one says
people say impossible
and I say let's find out
what's another good one
and
another one of them says the kid who
hasn't made it yet is trying to outwork
you
okay tell me one more I like those last
two I like the first one too but it just
doesn't apply to my life
I see you uh
one of them says what would Michael
Jordan do
okay and you ask yourself that every day
yeah yeah yeah because it's like he was
the best maybe one of the best athletes
ever so
I'm just thinking about that at all
times you know how much sacrifice do I
have to make what would Michael Jordan
do he would make the sacrifice what have
you had to sacrifice to become a boxer
everything fun
[Music]
sex food
time with my family sex yeah why
because you're only you're only allowed
to have sex like once a week and then
leading up to the fight you can you can
have sex for like three weeks
yeah you're supposed to build your
testosterone in your legs gotcha okay
uh yeah time with my family like
vacations Thanksgiving
Christmases birthdays that this is all
just in the past two years
um
yeah
birthday parties weddings
so for you what will ultimately make
that sacrifice worth it do you feel like
it's worth it now no it is it already is
current currently worth it for sure but
I want more I'm hungry
so I just for some
first a Content world where things are
likes and engagement and follows and
Views and things like that now to this
where it's like there's always going to
be like another fight another person
somebody else saying they like you or
don't like you there's always something
like
are you satisfied or will you ever be
satisfied will there always be like
another thing you'll have to do yeah I
think about this often you know will I
ever be satisfied and I don't I don't
know the answer to that yet
I think it might be no but
we'll see and
for me
you know I enjoy my life outside of the
chaos and
you know the work that I do and so I
think there will come a point where I'll
just ride off into the sunset and live
on a ranch with my family and have
horses and
ride dirt bikes and yeah just chill for
the rest of my life that's satisfying
but as far as like what I want to
accomplish
I don't know if I'll ever be satisfied
no I don't know I mean is that like
scary to think that you could be doing
all this but satisfaction isn't
necessarily the end goal that you'd
receive from it
it is and it isn't because I think the
greatest
people
ever Legends are never satisfied and so
they're constantly wanting to do more
even when they've done it all
and that's what makes them Legends and
that's what makes them great and maybe
that has a toll on them but
the way influences generations to come
is what makes it worth it
what is the thing and I don't want urine
to be winning because I don't believe
that to be true but like what's the
thing that ultimately drives you I mean
in all things like
why you know what I mean like what is it
hmm I think freedom
I think just the ability to
be free of
any
worry
and to be able to do whatever it is that
I want in life if I want to wake up one
day and fly to Paris on a jet then boom
if I want to wake up one day and
start a
Foundation then boom I could do that did
that you know if I want to wake up one
day and go on vacation for three months
then I could do that if I want to wake
up and go snowboarding I could do that
if I want to wake up and surprise my
girlfriend with the dopest date in the
world I could do that if I want to just
have kids and be a dad for the rest of
my life I could do that and I think
that's what drives me is just Freedom
yeah like being able to literally do
whatever you want at any time yeah
feel like it's being the Entertainer
that is the mean to that or is it being
the billionaire this means that like
what is the thing that actually gets you
there I think being a being a
billionaire for sure but I think it goes
hand in hand for me right now I think
it's like
what I do is you know make money from
entertainment and
currently invest it through my fund and
into crypto projects and nfts and that's
the stuff where you know
you compound your money into millions
and yeah I think
there's a certain
amount of money that you need in this
life to be able to retire
and live the life that you want and
still be able to pay those bills for the
rest of your life
I just I wonder how much
like I know you're saying you know you
reached a point where you don't
necessarily care what people are saying
about you the validation isn't the thing
but it's just so hard to operate in that
way when you are an Entertainer because
in a lot of ways that's inherently what
entertaining is
for sure you know there's
no there's one of the greatest feelings
is you know creating something and
having people appreciate it yeah
and we're taught that since we're kids
you know we're taught
mom look at the drawing and it's just a
scribbly little thing yeah and it sucks
but our parents are like that's amazing
and you're proud of it exactly so
there's there's innately we're taught
that as kids it creates something and
you want it to be liked and so yeah as
an Entertainer on on the biggest stage
of course you want you want to be liked
or respected I think for me it's boxing
it's like I want people to be like damn
that kid is good yeah you can fight okay
but
that's motivating yeah it's motivating
because you've done so many things and I
think that your life I would think what
your life looks like right now is not
what 10 year old Jake Paul envisioned
your life is maybe it's similar but it's
certainly not exactly this because I
don't know if it even existed right when
you were 10 years old but if 10 year old
Jake was looking at your life and what
they ended up doing tell me the thing
that 10 year old Jake would be the most
proud of that he did
hmm
I would say
you know getting to the place that I'm
at
and being surrounded by
amazing people and my own brother and
doing it alongside of him and having my
parents involvement and making them
proud
and
I think one of the dopest things that
I've always wanted to do was to create a
foundation and a charity I think the 10
year old Jake would be like that's dope
okay what's the thing 10 year old Jake
would be the most disappointed that you
did probably all the tattoos
I feel like you're resorting to humor
again
yeah yeah so I don't have a regression I
don't have regrets you know you have no
regrets nope it says it right there
and it's spelled wrong yeah like the
movie yeah
but I but you know disappointment
doesn't mean you regret it
I don't think about it so I guess I
really don't know like that's a really
honest answer I don't wake up and be
like man I'm disappointed today I feel
like that's terrible to do well I mean
what do you think it says about you you
don't think about things that maybe are
disappointing I mean I get I say oh
why'd I do that I think I think in the
moment if like you're disappointed in
something of course you have to reflect
change and learn from your mistakes but
I'm saying like
I don't constantly think about it I
think there's a lot of things there's a
laundry list you know of [ __ ] that I'm
disappointed in myself that I've done
but like
I've already moved on from it so it's
like wow well the things that you moved
on from that you did did you learn from
them
I mean for the most part 100 some of it
yes some of it I'm still learning it's
not an overnight process you know but
for sure just always learning always
trying to get better and
that's all you can do you know if people
are gonna hate on you for
doing something wrong
cool that's probably warranted but they
should also give you the chance to
get better
and to prove yourself
and to have a second chance yeah
I want to read a quote from you because
I think it's a really interesting quote
and something that in a lot of ways I I
agree with you said in a New Yorker
article you said one thing that is great
about being a fighter is you can't get
canceled yeah what do you think it is
about being a fighter that like
insulates people from this cancellation
which nobody has ever really canceled
just for the record no of course yeah of
course okay
I I think because
as a fighter you are literally doing the
most barbaric
thing humanly possible the only way to
legally kill somebody is in the boxing
ring or an octagon
they're the only way to legally kill
somebody in today's society
kind of crazy to think about that so you
are literally doing the most barbaric
thing you're putting your life on the
line you're risking everything and
you have to be I think you have to be
crazy almost to do that and
I think people
the fight fans the fight audience the
the sport they don't really care about
what happens outside of the Ring because
they just want to see about boxing
though
because I do agree that that's true but
I'm like well is that
yeah I mean it's probably for crazy
people for sure it is what it is you
know
it's the modern day gladiators
boxing has just evolved from when they
would throw a guy in there with a sword
against a lion in front of the whole
entire Arena
and the whole entire Arena would either
watch a man get eaten by a lion or the
man would conquer the the lion with a
sword and so boxing has just evolved
Gladiators yeah and so I think
it's we're humans it's hard to shake
that feeling of wanting to see two
people just go at it yeah
people love it I love it it's just funny
how easy it is to like not like a boxer
I'm a different I don't really care
about anybody but I understand like the
emotions that it illicits you
specifically but it's just so easy to
say okay
I don't want to root for this person and
just for you to say like it doesn't
weigh on you and all that people are so
actively not rooting for you it's like
they believe it but it's hard to believe
because human nature is to like even if
maybe don't care as much you do want
them to but they do you know it's like
50 50. so it's like if it was all bad
and everyone like I was literally like
the worst person in the world and it was
all hate then yeah that would probably
be I wouldn't like that but it's not
that I have so much love I have an
abundance of love
and to me the positivity outweighs all
the negativity and you know the people
and the Legends who have taken me under
their wing and shown support in the
boxing community
that means more than anything that you
know Macho Man 44 on Twitter could say
I don't give a [ __ ]
well you know
I think that when you really step back
and think of it do you
recognize or understand why certain
people are hesitant to be a fan of yours
due to the sexual assault allegations do
you recognize the hesitancy because of
that sure
for sure 100 you know that's that's
something that's like uh
thing that I'll have to live with for
the rest of my life 100 and when you
when someone's accused of something
people's you know natural instinct is
to just believe whatever is said that's
the generation we live in you know the
media paints a picture of whatever it is
that they want to paint and we're on our
iPhones scrolling through and we just
see a headline and we're like oh yep
that's true so there's a lot of reasons
why you know people are hesitant to
embrace me or be be a fan and I I get it
you know I get it if I was on the
outside looking in I'd be like hmm at
face value like I'd be like I don't know
about this kid
I really don't
but if I took the time to
understand me and dig a little bit
deeper
I think that's where that's when someone
becomes a fan or they could see my you
know they could see who I actually am
okay I know you you know you released a
statement about and of course for all
people sexual assault allegations of
something everybody can and should take
incredibly seriously you know you don't
want to take away her voice the same way
that you have a voice as well but I do
think it's interesting and this is about
society as a whole that a lot of the
times all people have to do is like deny
something and they're able to go about
the rest of their lives where the person
who Maybe
accuse you she said she gets death
threats and
there's just always going to be an
imbalance even though it's not even
about what exactly happened there's
always an imbalance that exists I mean
just because it's between women and men
and do you ever wish maybe when she was
getting those death threats you said
okay you guys calm down like I don't
want this
to be what's happening to her yeah no I
mean no one deserves death threats yeah
you know so
I mean no one should have sent her death
threats you know that's not that's not
the proper way to deal with yeah she
accuses I deny
cool it should be what it is but no my
fans shouldn't like go attack her no not
at all okay in a general sense I think
it's fair to say that boxing kind of has
a culture of misogyny is that something
that you think can be changed
I think so
a hundred percent
I think it needs to change you know and
I think that's the beautiful thing about
our society is everything's out there
everything's on camera everyone has a
voice and so I think people
really second guess things when they
when they do it you know they they
realize the Everlasting effects of what
could happen so I think as a society We
are Becoming better people 100 yeah yeah
is there things that you feel like
boxers specifically can do to battle
that because as someone obviously who's
a woman that is an issue that a lot of
women have with boxing and why they
decide not to watch it is because they
just feel like it's so apparent in the
sport which is that because it's a fun
sport yeah
I mean I think the only way is to talk
about it like how we are now yeah and
that can trickle down but
you know it's hard why do you think
people should watch Boxing what makes
boxing you know a good sport yeah
it's not my job to convince them yeah
you know I
if they don't watch Boxing like I don't
care don't watch it then okay well tell
me how your match is going to go you
against Fury how's that going to go walk
me through it
but be careful because when this happens
I'm gonna like we're gonna do a side by
side of the fight and what you said of
course so I'm saying right by it 100 uh
we're gonna get in there
I think feel each other out
first couple of rounds
he's gonna feel the power I have
instantly gets scared
and not know what hit him he's gonna
realize he was thrown in with a dog
he's slowly gonna crumble
and my momentum is going to build and
build and build as the rounds go by and
fifth or sixth round I'm knocking him
out
okay
and you're 100 sure this is a win it's
happening it's a wrap 100 guaranteed
people will see a Jake Paul they've
never seen before
and
I'm excited to just show you know I talk
a lot but
for me
this one is about
you know proving the whole world that I
can knock out a professional boxer this
is the this is the sweetest one for me
this is the most important one for me
and I'm gonna sit here and talk and say
all these things but on December 18th
I'm going to back it up and what will
winning that signify
I think it'll just show like hey
this kid came in and in less than two
years flipped this sport on its head
beat some amazing excuse me beat some
amazing Fighters
and uh he's the real deal
and has such a bright future
and that we should respect this kid and
all that he's doing
and it'll show young kids that hey you
know even if millions of people are
saying you can't do something then
then you can do it
Frank or Darren Williams
pick
[Laughter]
[Music]
man Frank Gore was looking good on the
mids he's got the he's got a size
disadvantage though
and uh apparently
Mr Williams has been training in MMA for
years and I haven't seen a video of him
hitting the mitts yet
so in my opinion I think both of them
have so much pride and ego I think it's
gonna be an amazing fight if I had to
pick I
I got to see a video of Mr Williams but
I would I would just say him just
because of his height and his reach
Darren yeah Darren's gonna win for sure
okay
that you were talking about your fights
and like what you'd want and you go I
mean there's an NFL player who wants to
fight me but you didn't say who it was
what NFL player wants to fight you
there was a couple I think one of them
was Frank Gore that's how we knew he
wanted a fight okay uh
uh at some point he was calling me out
there was another one too
I forget who it was who would we be like
most surprised to hear has had an
interest in fighting you
oh wow
I don't even know there's so many names
I'm trying to think of like the craziest
one
chocolate dough like Mike Tyson
Roy Jones Jr
uh
the the list really goes on
I'm forgetting like tons of names there
was like some random like actor that was
hilarious really oh you gotta thank you
I don't even know I'm I'll think about
it okay yeah yeah I get it back to it so
we're almost done so just get back to us
um tell me your dream like NBA fight two
current players fight you're like this
is a good matchup and tell me the winner
foreign
It's gotta be
LeBron versus
Giannis
and who wins
I think
I think Giannis would win you think
Giannis would be LeBron yeah just what
gives him the advantage
I think he's just a little bit bigger
and he's a little bit more Scrappy
okay I think LeBron wouldn't like to get
hit because he always flops
and the flopping would translate over
yeah because when you get hit in the
head everything changes and
that's when it's like oh wow this is
boxing yeah I mean I always say about
fighting not boxing whatever box but
fighting it's really about like getting
hit because if you've never been punched
it's like a shock to you like someone
intentionally trying to hit you with
something you have to like rebound from
very quickly yeah I got into a fight
once in college I was like oh my gosh it
was very quick so it was like dude I
like win sure but it wasn't like a it
wasn't a real thing yeah yeah but I
remember getting hit and I was like dang
like like getting hit is the is the
thing it's easy to like throw a punch
but you gotta be ready to you know it's
back um okay tell me your dream NBA
fight I mean NFL fight I'm sorry
it would be funny to see some
quarterbacks go at it
I want to see if Aaron Rodgers got hands
okay
and
maybe Baker Mayfield versus Aaron
Rodgers
winner
I think Baker would win Baker meets
Aaron yeah why you choose Baker
Aaron Aaron's a little old now I think
he's like 40 something
so Baker would be have that youth yeah
he's gonna get him out of there he's
gonna move quicker okay tell me one
thing before I let you go
one thing that people should leave this
with
hmm
their dignity
okay elaborate people should leave with
their dignity
I don't know I don't know if you should
leave with I mean just
who knows I don't know
maybe a different point of view
of me I don't know okay or
second thoughts who knows I don't really
know I do think that was probably the
hardest question he asked honestly
funny though you really should look into
like how you always go to make a joke is
that bad though
it's just like such a defense mechanism
like I want to go to the joke you
probably told like five jokes in
response because like I'm not that
serious yeah like what should people
and then like the crazy music comes in
yeah I think that's what you were going
for but I'm just not that serious like
yeah I don't care
I don't care what people leave it with
yeah so like I tried to answer your
question but it was like you're like I
don't know I don't my tattoos yeah like
I don't know comedy yeah because I'm
again
do you think life's easier for you that
way 100
yeah
110
it makes it so much more fun
and everything's a joke and it's just
like clowning people and making fun of
myself that's how we are with each other
like my team like
people get on each other's heads yeah
and it's just more fun I don't know and
in the weirdest most interesting way it
has totally worked for you so thank you
keep it up or don't you're telling me
you're telling me to like go see like a
therapist
you go to I resort to Comedy no but
honestly I mean I I do like therapy I
think everyone should try therapy I
don't think necessarily you should but
it is a thing yeah no for sure yeah
maybe maybe I'll
maybe I'll work on that yeah
maybe I'll check back in
let's do it like next year or something
he has to come back to Puerto Rico any
free trip to Puerto Rico that there is
I'll take it amazing thank you for your
time